[Music]
have you guys ever imagined what life
would be like
if you basically were off the grid
didn't have an id card no official
records no license
medical insurance bank account anything
like truly
on what terms would that be for you like
uh what is the
immediate like scenario that you did you
just give less [ __ ] because
how are you like you can do literally
whatever the [ __ ] you want what about
food we're gonna eat for food
you're gonna eat fried squirrels and
[ __ ] i mean you could plant [ __ ]
like why can't i think it's all fun
until you want to travel and then you
don't have a passport yeah
yeah you don't exist yeah you don't
exist damn that's true i heard a podcast
a girl she her she got her born out in
some farm or something like that and
her mom thought she was being you know
super like
hippie-ish and then she's adult now she
can't work she can't do nothing
she doesn't exist she's no social
security nothing
yes you can't move you like you said
passport but you can't yeah and she's
like i'm trying to live in the city and
do my thing and i don't i'm not even
really here
crazy yeah what she needs to become a
super villain then i know you don't
think that we
we're we're so connected we feel we're
not connected we're
more connected than we do our [ __ ]
phones open up with our
face that's [ __ ] connected i know we
are connected but like
all those a social security number and
like
i know you don't think about that much
but it's kind of important yeah but it's
kind of a little bit
doing this but like being having the
freedom is have 10 fake identities and
different countries
like a spy you know and then you have
all these different passports or
whatever
because right now if you want to travel
it's like oh well you're a u.s citizen
so you can't go to europe
but what if i had a japanese passport i
could go maybe i could go
you know japan only lets you have a
japanese passport that's
it one passport i mean bahama people
it's all made up stuff you know what i'm
saying like i have this passport i have
this social security number but guess
what if i just threw it in the garbage
now what do i have
it's a digital they're like
[Laughter]
oh i guess so you're still in the system
somehow i know but like i don't
you just take off the system that
doesn't make you think like back in the
day before they had computers where
it's just in the system like you need to
have physical written
records of everything and i was like if
you how do you know how much money you
had which is a millionaire
that's why people will be balancing
their checkbooks it's all [ __ ] like
you know you're
traveling and you're you know you're
sleeping on the plane traveling
internationally it's always trip like
you gotta fill this out
right like oh you're like freak out then
you like gotta find a pen and you're
trying to fill out the stupid form
that you give to the guy on the way
outside the airport that what the [ __ ]
are they doing those forms
it's more yeah yeah immigration they put
in a pile you see the guy putting in a
stack of stuff
they're not punching it they're not
doing [ __ ] as soon as you guys leave he
just throws out the trash
what the [ __ ] are we doing half of the
times when i go through like tsar
customs right and i looked at this white
guy in the eyes and i know i'm the first
agent he ever saw
and he looks at my passport and goes
mm-hmm i'm like [ __ ] i could
have someone else's passport dude
little tsa cats are like i get it after
them but i'm like they're not ready
hey ready if there was some real
terrorists coming through here
that dude and that chick ain't ready for
it no
and they seem to think that some
terrorists from other countries are like
some like guys that can get stopped at
tsa
yeah that's like the james bonds from
their countries
it's like as our cia fbi guys get
stopped at another country's tsa
no what the hell are we doing but yeah
so
living life without a uh an identity
might sound pretty cool in a sense like
james bond
like jason bourne for the weekend sounds
kind of cool for the weekend i think for
a week
for that's true uh but for one french
woman in particular
uh a 58 year old french woman named
jeanne
i don't know i can't pronounce it that's
yeah but uh for her life is a nightmare
she is a nightmare nightmare how do you
say it do you say it it's nightmare
how do you say it nightmare
just sucks man but yeah so she's been
officially declared dead
for the past three years why for three
years
she has had you cannot be here you are
dead
how are you here this is impossible
this is
i know country the country uh yeah so
for three years she's
had no official records of her she's
lost her id card
driver's license medical insurance bank
account what happened
uh like she physically lost it or they
took it away from her because she took
away
they declared all that stuff invalid
obsolete
how did she die so how did she die well
obviously she is not dead she's alive
and well
so this is a picture of her that's so
stupid
[ __ ]
why did they put a picture on the
[ __ ] cat that's so distracting
i think you're supposed to feel sorry
for her
so how did you get declared dead all
right so she got declared dead because
she was being sued by a former employee
so she runs a
a cleaning service and she had to cut
jobs or whatever the employee wasn't
happy so took her to court
for whatever reasons and killed her
basically basically
through the whole process uh jeannette
she
didn't really respond to a whole lot of
the court hearing like you know the
court dates and all that stuff she
didn't really show up she didn't
like this
and so when she did that when she failed
to show up and
failed to uh answer phone calls and
things like that
uh the plaintiff the ex-employee came in
and said they're not they're not
responding they must be dead
and for whatever reasons whatever
happened here
the court was like oh yeah they're dead
yeah with no
with no proof no death certificate no
nothing
she was declared dead and in that moment
all her [ __ ] got wiped out it was a
conspiracy
and now she's been and because of
bureaucracy for the past three years
she's
she's been trying to prove that she's
alive and she's even presented herself
alive in court in front of a judge and
for some reason the system like whatever
bureaucracy bullshit's happening to her
she can't damn this employee no
no no no no you see this paper says you
are dead this is impossible
next next go out next
get
is really well connected damn you know
what's crazy you can start a whole
business of
like you know like killing people like
we're hitting but like we're not
hitmen of like yeah we're not physically
hitting people
but we're like digital hitman we're just
we're like we'll kill that person and we
can
kill people out then just ruin their
lives it seems like it's easy to do
you just you make a suggestion that's
like our new tv show the digital hitman
yeah but this makes their country look
bad it makes it look like they're super
stupid
there's a it reminds me of this book
i've been i read this book sapiens
have you read yeah i love that book can
we have like a book group just talking
about this book because like this is
it's a good book yeah what book sapiens
you guys should receive but we should
just do a
talk every week about sapience what is
it about
the the history of humanity of humanity
in
humans homo sapiens but the thing is i
love history the thing about what it is
is like this
is reality is none of this shit's real
none of this [ __ ] yeah
it's all about it's man-made stories
yeah
and that's the only thing that puts us
above any other animals they said is
that we got
language other animals have language but
our language got good enough where we
can create
fiction once we create fiction then we
can create all these
things and like obviously all this [ __ ]
that even her dead or life it's not real
she's alive but
all this [ __ ] the fake [ __ ] that we made
states and laws and
[ __ ] because we're born into it
right so then you think that
this physical place that's existing
is real but it's all mandatory nations
and laws it's like it's just
us agreeing on current money just like
oh yeah that's uh so why do we agree on
any of this
question that that is that's why
anarchists don't believe in it i know
you know how you can expedite this
lady's process just tell her to go
commit a crime i bet you finding files
real quick go rob a bank go kill someone
all of a sudden oh i got your record
right here
i'm alive now what oh now
she has attitude you don't see me [ __ ]
she has a money bag i mean it's
impossible i'm not i'm not alive
that would be a good time i mean
obviously you can't rob a bank because
they can still
shoot your body oh truck true you can do
a crime but it's france dude they don't
use guns they use baguettes
you might get hit by that stella hey you
know oh yeah they go a god
but if she hit some cyber crime she just
got so just got like she robbed somebody
of like
10 bitcoins like who got it that dead
woman she can't set up a bitcoin account
though
oh yeah you can't i know coinbase won't
because you gotta have an id
for that she's got action
she has to rob some stuff like an old
school thief yep
and then the sack with the money exactly
with the [ __ ] dollar signs on it
with a black thing on her eyes yeah so
she's actually
afraid to go out now because she doesn't
want
the trouble of being stopped by law
enforcement or anything realizing that
she doesn't have
uh she doesn't have an identity or isn't
even alive and just
like being exaggerated bro like why are
they gonna pull her like she's a lady
with the fat cat like no one's paying
attention
you know what we have illegal immigrants
in america all day
long
just [ __ ] live your life live your
life that's good advice
yeah why are they going to be like
you're just an illegal immigrant in your
own country
what's going to happen that's it
yeah what's going to happen if she does
go to jail or whatever like what yeah do
the cops do
now what's gonna happen with that fat
cat you know that ink that they try to
get her fingerprints with like she's
gonna do it and there's nothing
like it's gonna go in the system people
that have nothing and then the cops are
gonna be like exactly blue
he's a ghost he's a ghost get out
of here he's a ghost sorry france
everyone thinks that she's a dead person
dead been walking what would you do if
you if no you couldn't get caught
because of her like you can't get caught
like her like her yeah i'm too lazy i'm
doing nothing same
i don't know i try to do one thing what
what what's the one thing
i don't know oh you just want one thing
you know the mackie store
just just ganked that place not at all
just take two pair of shoes well all
they're gonna see is a shoe floating
away right
because you're dead i know she's fine
she's
essentially like an illegal immigrant
yeah in her own she's like illegal in
her own country dude
she's gonna get deported but wait wait
she can't wait
but the great thing is you can't get
deported so you're basically she also
doesn't have any money i feel like it
but they don't really cover this in the
article but
yeah she doesn't have a bank account she
don't gotta pay taxes where the [ __ ] did
her money go
she ain't gotta pay taxes a lot of
homeless people are like that dude
here what a lot of homeless people are
like that here
like you know when you um when you don't
have any family members
and then you have like a mental like
condition or something you can't
remember
there's a lot of people out here that
don't remember you can't get those
images you can't you have
yeah you can't remember your social
security whatever it is
they don't know what they're yeah and
that's why we have a bunch in la too
[Music]
[Music]
you